hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
answer a question from one of our
newsletter readers has Celine who wrote
in asking about how to increase sales at
his company so he says in his
manufacturing business they create
bolder Pistons and he's trying to figure
out how to get more sales thank you for
the question a great question and what I
love about this business is that it's
b2b if you can especially at the
beginning if you can sell to a business
it's a lot easier to get the money you
need to grow your business than for
selling the customers and the reason
being they'll order more from you so the
order values are usually a lot higher
than going out to individual consumers
and they usually make repeat purchases
the idea of selling to b2b is you want
to make yourself a really valuable and
important part of their company and if
you are if you're providing great value
then they're gonna keep hiring you back
and buying more whatever your product or
service is so if you can ideally go out
there b2b market at the start because it
gives you the money you need to launch
and grow your business so this is great
that it's a manufacturing company
selling b2b now I don't know much of
boiler pistons but it doesn't matter too
much what the first piece of advice
would give you is you need to come up
with you know what makes you stand out
against your competition so it's great
that you sell boiler pistons but what's
so great about your boiler pistons
hopefully there's something that you
have that you know it's stand by if it's
your guarantee of quality or you know
you do things with your boiler Pistons
that other companies can't you want to
make sure that that's really clear so
that when people are making a decision
between your company and somebody else
they know you're the guys who do XYZ and
it may not make sure that you win every
single order because they may not have a
specific need that matches up with what
you offer but they'll be able to clearly
understand what separates you for your
competition and know if they should be
buying from you or not so that would be
the first step is understand really what
separates you from your competition the
next thing that I would do and this is
works especially well when you're
selling the business it's over deliver
like crazy so you over deliver on the
service side of your business so you
want to think about all the different
areas
you can add amazing service so that they
want to keep coming back to you if you
think about businesses they want to work
with companies who will you know
basically give them everything that they
need right they don't want to have any
problems they want to have a smooth
relationship and if you can provide
amazing service
that's an awesome way to first get a
really small order and then explode from
there so the basics of service they're
obviously you know giving the client
what they want being available answering
their questions very quickly doing
everything you can to help them you know
with with their orders but you want to
try to go above and beyond try to give
them information or knowledge or service
or anything else you can think of that
can help them grow their business beyond
what you're just doing for them as a
supplier so can you give them some
customers can you you know refer media
or partners to them can you help them
raise capital if that's what they're
looking for can you give them knowledge
about what's happening in your industry
that might make them have better
information and give them that
information to grow their business you
want to keep thinking of different ways
to really over deliver so that they want
to hire you back what I love doing is
when I go into businesses is I try to
think on a really small project so I
don't go in and bid on you know the huge
project because if they have incumbent
suppliers which is probably gonna be the
case for you there's already a supplier
that's helping them it can be really
hard to dislodge them so what you want
to do is go on with just trying to get
one small simple tiny order from them
make it low-risk you know you're just
trying you out your you're not asking
for a lot of money or a lot of time it's
not really gonna damage your
relationship with the other supplier
it's just a trial it's easy you get them
to say yes and that's your goal just get
them to say yes on a small simple trial
and then you blow their mind with the
service that you provide so I'm assuming
that your product is good and we'll do
everything that you say it's gonna do
you know if you're there if your boiler
pistons are not great then you can't
really count on repeat orders but I'm
gonna see when they get a good product
so from there it's all the service you
add on top of it so what can you do to
really stand out from your competition
and give them more service and more
information compared to everybody else
so that they love working with you
they're gonna order more from you on the
next project they're gonna you know
double triple quadruple
the the order sighs from you and refer
other divisions to you refer other
clients to you it grows and it grows
from providing that awesome service so
it's a thin wedge in tiny little order
low-risk just get them to try you out
and from there blow their minds away
it's really gotta be something special
they've got a supplier they're dealing
with and they're already happy with them
you've got to really blow their socks
off
to make an impression and make them want
to do more business with you
so that's your challenge but it's an
exciting opportunity a lot of businesses
don't do that extra mile they just do
you know what's required the basic so
there's an opportunity for you to jump
in there especially with established
industries like you know manufacturing
typically things are done a certain way
and people don't really go too far above
and beyond so it's an awesome
opportunity for you so hopefully that
helps for you watching the video if you
liked it please give it a thumbs up it
makes you want to do more of these
videos for you guys it gives me a boost
every day when I come in and see that
there's spin some thumbs up on the video
so thank you and if you have a comment
about this video or you have a question
for your company feel free to leave it
in the comments below I always read
those and try to respond as many as I
can so thank you and you'll see you on
the next episode
you